what is happening what's up gamers it's
me
poppy Mary Hamm gaming time a new show
that I'm launching where we play a game
from start to finish smash like
subscribe if you are a gamer today we're
playing kids that's right I thought it
would fit you 9 year olds there's
another game by the same creator called
plug and play I played it a few years
ago and it was like going on a trip and
so let's just do that lets go gamers
let's go on a gaming journey what in the
world is happening that's a hole don't
jump
whatever you do do not jump down the
goddamn it okay I click and they fall
that's fantastic there you go you will
all go everyone has to go except Jurgen
come on you're good you stay
we're cool right we go to Chuck E Cheese
right Jurgen don't do it
Jurgen I know it looks grim but don't do
it god damn it I clicked on it it was me
can I save them oh I save you here again
you're with me we go up
nevermind Oh
oh okay do you like it beautiful look at
them go
little babies naked babies away I can't
say that YouTube algorithm I didn't say
anything I swear I said the Hep B
real-estate I'm looking at houses right
now that's right
epic I don't know what the point of this
is but I enjoy it
ah are you alive
he's fine look he's fine don't worry
about it all right this is the tough
choice hi or hello I'm I'm a simple kind
of guy I made the wrong choice god damn
god damn kids alright does he this way
Kochi all right we're goin down the hole
again because why not
everyone knows the golden rule of holes
you gotta enter them hey this way this
way no all right what is the hit
all right let's do a nice little jump
that's it I almost synchronized
Oh God why is it pulsing why is it
polishing
Oh God ooh oh god it's a pooper oh we're
getting pooped out it's fine this
happens to everyone everyone has to get
poop we've all done this we've all
experienced this let's not pretend that
this isn't natural
damn this is how it looks like every
time you poop just so you know just
you're aware of that oh god it's got to
go out - hey Ana stop you're going back
this guy's going back he doesn't want
goddamn II can't go back all right let's
just break the barrier this is break
that it's a nipple this is our nipples
are born this is an educational video
now look oh god now go back in now I'm
not doing it oh my god
me and the boys after we become living
nipples all right get going boys all
right you were supposed to go together
but fine all right just go oh god
they're so fast oh god there's so many
of you stop they've been busy pooping
our boys excuse me oh I'm sorry like
you've never done it
Jesus Christ dude they're just more and
more it's ugly visually pleasing this
game watch it in 1080p 60 frames it's
epic alright oh I'd say that's what I
want
there's no more pooping that's all I ask
this way this way come on guys know that
Jesus Christ get along please this way
agree okay all right no that way no this
way
do you even know what you're saying
alright so this way this way yes agreed
agreed
you made a compelling argument yes
that's the way uh-huh uh-huh Oh Jack
paid me okay I'm sorry
what are you they doing now I know why
I'm surprised of course he jumps in
everyone everyone go oh Jesus Christ oh
my god stop hey hey
that's right no more holes never we
don't do that anymore what is this
okay join them that's right
together we are strong we'd run away
from holes
our paths have changed no oh my god stop
hey again I think I have to yeah it's
kind of fun I want to do it it's not
fair man you look I'm swimming boy in
space boy this is epic I kind of look
like a bunny with a clown nose or
something like that all right oh god
damn it not this again I just go through
quick poop it out this makes me want to
poop oh god what is this now where they
connect just go just go just go just go
through thank you
sounds too
I don't like it can I mute this at least
you can mute the video Jesus Christ it
sounds just like when I have too much
spicy food
seriously Oh God not the nipple all
right fine
oh god there's so many nipples go back
go back
I don't we're not doing this we're not
doing this anymore fine yeah wake up
jargon oh my god
Italia is so visually pleasing very epic
all right what are we doing boom boom
that doesn't work I wanted to do that we
can do mean review clap clap there are
nine year old I knew it meme review oh I
can charge it okay oh alright alright
alright imagine like if you do it at
home like how many million people are
gonna clap at the same time ok 3 2 1
meme review
all right that didn't it didn't really
work what happened I won't do it do it I
won't do it do it I won't do it how
might you do it you do it no you do it
do what know you know you know you know
you know you know know you really know
you the game everyone know that news
should do it yes okay I like it all
right all right I'll do it
well across the bridge someone's got to
do it keeps ramming bunny weird like it
come on it looks like a bunny don't lie
to me
we're going against the grain boys why
they running away from me what's wrong
okay fine I swim this way then I don't
care
it's whatever and then even care can tan
there's so many of them what am I
supposed to go sideways
okay that's epic this is the thing of
these games you never know what's gonna
happen oh my god that's so hypnotizing
for my eyes okay we made it amazing now
white Oh God upside down nipple
[Music]
you would have fall now
if your kids ever ask you how kids are
born
just show them this video I think that's
the only way to explain properly
[Applause]
beautiful 10 out of 10 performance
[Music]
unified
[Applause]
oh Jesus okay all right everybody on
three everyone's gonna clap meme review
it's gonna be epic
yeah you too all nipples mode must go
back to where they came from swim
against the green doesn't seem to do it
okay fine
how did you even do this weird such a
weird game such a strange game about
kids and hot whoo kids and holes down
they go it's like a metaphor for life
and like how holes are out goddamnit at
the pooping god dammit I don't like this
it's gonna be like a an ant banding
we'll just make you go like oh okay so
that's why they swim through the poop oh
that makes so much sense now I feel bad
for judging the game now this is about
the whole new perspective saying I I
assume everyone's gonna be thrilled that
I'm playing games again and this is the
kind of case now there's like a
three-way but taller
Oh God that makes sense Oh God don't
think about it just pulse through the
pupper just pulse through the pooper
just like life we all got to do it it's
a dirty job goddamn it why are you late
come on there you go
ah God ah God Jake sighs hi guys what's
up its me Jurgen the nipple man Hey what
I thought we were friends
come on guys come on come on why are
they chasing me ah please someone give
me a hug I swear I don't have leave me
please
come on guys what is happening oh we
made it
screw you guys I don't like you anyway
all right we've been through this many
times before just go in now come on dude
I need oh I'm sorry that's funny
oh god we're doing the clap again all
right here we go guys
clap time I mean review this is
nine-year-old watching meme review
that's the metaphor the creator of this
game was a nine year old and back it
goes and back to the center Oh Mike to
the other side we're doing the wave okay
all right okay okay all right we get
everyone Oh another one
amazing such coordination absolutely
incredible I thought I could send it
away or something I don't know I was
trying ideas Oh God not this again no
that way that's way yes yes that's way
why we agreed agreed no this way oh all
right then
oh god what have I done
Oh God are there's so many this is like
a metaphor for herd mentality never
follow what other people say do what you
wanna do
there is no individualism your life is
meaningless you just like everyone else
as much as you like to pretend that you
are different and as much as people tell
you you are unique you are really just a
nine year old and there's not
they look like banana peels running tit
no all right click on the stop saying I
need subbies and sexual objects for
everything Jesus Christ is it gonna get
filled up now it's kind of creepy
[Music]
I'm sure a top common of this video will
know exactly what this is all about
right someone figured out it they're
like oh yeah of course
the meaning behind it is bunnies and
banana peels and that's whoa
down you go my sweet children I love you
sorry nine heroes but we must all jump
down keep jumping
why don't you jump back that's what I
thought that's what I freakin thought
come on get in
Jesus Christ oh yeah it's getting
smaller it's gonna get filled up no
one's gonna be able to jump in after a
while no just me
get in
right side top side bottom side we get
everyone here yeah it's like shaving a
chest why did I say that and there we go
[Music]
it's everyone yay awesome go down my
child
then let's learn for kids my child Ren
you did it I'm so proud of you my 9 year
olds I expect this to get him trending I
expect this to get billions abuse at
least 20 million this has been Papa
Gloria gaming and I am about to stay off
because the game is done I think I'm not
sure maybe oh I'd say this when you why
you need to drink G fuel I already had
one today I want to overdo it you are
welcome thank you for watching
smash like subscribe and remember keep
gaming my name is Papa Gloria gamer gay
Gaga team